my scooter Odyssey continues through
Volpe's pork
unfortunately my resounding victory over
the Volkswagen and yesterday's race is
not without its consequences
my back hurts so bad I have to stop at
an orthopedist office for a series of
treatments hope they do the trick
I'm now 26 days out of zoats and have
clocked up 689 kilometers in my quest to
reach Germany's southernmost points just
1798 left to go and 64 days left to go
them in but I'm not destined to make up
any time today after just a few clicks I
meet artists and journeyman on their
traditional vaults or walkabout
they're currently working on a
construction site this walkabout
actually like the vines is a journey
lasting three years and a day that
journeyman artisans can take if they
want during that time you learn about
new work methods new countries new
cultures different customs Wow sounds
like a plan any drawbacks
isn't it pretty tough to be on the road
for so long not at all because you're
always on the move you don't really
notice it and in the wintertime you
often get an invitation to spend the
night from people you might have met
hitchhiking or on the train in summer
you have a sleeping bag and then it's
always nicest to sleep outside under the
stars some stomach so to go knock that
does low if the shoe there's also time
for relaxation on the vaults the young
artisans show me a cafe that caters
specifically to wandering journeyman the
outfit they wear is very symbolic there
are eight mother-of-pearl buttons on
both trousers and vest which stand for
the eight hours of the working day
different colors reveal different trades
carpenters wear black while Mason's are
dressed in light gray an earring is also
standard the ear is pierced with a nail
hammered through with one decisive
stroke
why do you all have an earring don't
wing it's a tradition from the old days
the earring was used to pay for the
journeyman's funeral if he died on his
walkabout German journeyman have been
wandering around the country since the
12th century to learn new methods and
gather the experience they need to
eventually become master artisans
nowadays however there are only around
500 journeyman on the road at any given
time in Germany around 10% of them women
people from a wide variety of crafts
take the trip including bookbinders the
Walkabout is also a tradition in Austria
Switzerland France and Denmark after so
much information I want to get an idea
of what this feels like so I offer to
work for meal and accommodation for the
night
I'm on a walkabout and would like to
work for food and lodging well we don't
have any work okay nothing to be done
then thanks bye like to offer labour in
exchange for food and shelter have you
gotten anything for me this banana and
five euros and I don't have to do
anything for it now I'm giving them to
you yes I have lots to do at home I'm
glad to give you something to do in the
gardens do you have anything to eat or
drink with me yes with you a package of
spaghetti two thirds of the Germans I
asked we're willing to give food money
or lodging I think for my next series
I'll go into vaults myself
glimpses into a world I've always been
curious about the tradition is no longer
as common as it once was but it hasn't
died out yet
time to turn my back on Wolfsburg and
wander further south the pressures
mounting and completing my own role
about in 80 days is beginning to look
like an almost insurmountable challenge